[موسيقى]
طب مساكم
نتحدث اليوم عن زياره البابا فرنسيس الى
البحرين المجتمعون هناك يتحدثون عن
التعايش الانساني من الشعارات والاماني
الى الواقع موضوعنا الثاني هو الانتخابات
التشريعيه الاسرائيليه التي اوصلت الى
الحكم بنيامين نتنياه مره اخرى واقع جديد
سيكون له اثر مباشر على الفلسطينيين
والقضيه الفلسطينيه هي من اهم ما ناقشه
الزعماء العرب في القمه العربيه التي
احتضنتها الجزائر ومن الجزائر تلتحق بنا
مديره جريده الفجر الجزائريه
الزميله حدها هزار مرحبا بك حدها
ويكون معنا ايضا من لندن للكاتب السياسي
الاستاذ اكرم عطا الله ومن القاهره الكاتب
السياسي احمد جمعه اهلا بكم جميعا ااا من
هناك من الجزائر من الجناح الغربي للعالم
العربي والاسلامي كيف تنظرين الى الزياره
هداء هزام التي يقوم بها الباب الفرنسيس
الى الجناح الشرقي من العالم العربي
والاسلام هناك في البحرين
ومفروض علينا
وجه المعموره لكن اعتقد ان هيا ااه محاوله
لتنوي الصوره في في دوله البحرين وكنت
افضل ان يكون الحوار يعني بين الشيعه
والسنه لانه هناك همم هناك ضغط كبير على
المواطنين الشيعه في في البحرين وهناك
اقصاء لهم من كثير من همم
وظائف هناك يعني يعني ضغط كبير عليهم في
الحقيقه كنت افضل ان يبدا الحوار بين
المسلمين انفسهم حتى نذهب وحده ااه واحده
واحده لمحاوره الغرب ومحاوره الديانات
الاخرى سواء كانت مسيحيه او يهوديه لان
مثل الحوار ضروري لانه الحل الوحيد لحل
الازمات وحل الخلافات وحل اا يعني سوء
الفهم في اكثر همم في الكثير من الاحيان
بين الشعوب من جانب الدين نعم دكتوره
اكرمت لها من لندن ذا السؤال ذاته تقييمك
لهذه الزياره
واهميته همم روحي له مكان روحيه في العالم
الذي يمكن ان يحدث تغييره
حروب وصراعات ومجاعات
وانحسر دور
وموقف البابا خلال سنوات الماضيه ولم يكن
له دور وربما خلال فتره الحرب البارده
صوره البابويه في العالم عندما كشف انه
هناك انه يضعون مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
اصبح الزياره بروتوكول صوتي جميل من
الجزائر عندما قالت انه البحرين اخر ما
تحتاجه لزياره البابا ليس هناك مشكله بين
الديانات المشكله في اطار الدين الاسلامي
الواحد الذي يهرب من نقاش قضيه الخاصه
قضيه الشيعه ثم حتى الان بل ويسعر هذا
الصراع بين الجانبين الصراع يتمظهر في
لبنان يتمظهر في اليمن تمظهر فيه بعض دول
الخليج يتضملها في العراق وفي سوريا
وربما ان تربينات الشحن خلال سنوات
الماضيه كانت اكثر لكن لا يزال هذا هذا
المساله هذه المساله لن تحل
[موسيقى]
ربما علقت كما هو لكنه موجود موجود
البحرين
لكنها لا يمكن النظر الي هذا البعد وهم
بخصوصا انه العالم زاهر
الحركه ان تكون هناك الحرب العالميه
الثالثه حرب عالميه ثالثه لكن
يتوسع السلاح جغرافيا السلاح وبالتالي همم
دور البابا ماذا يكون وسط عالم يتبدل
العالم تتغير موازين القوه الرباويه
السنين كانت حال مهمه كانت تحرك جيوش كانت
تفرض تمنع حروب لكن الان لم يعد لها ذلك
الدور الذي يمكن النظر اليه باعتبار الشيء
وشان في العالم السياسي قلت انا زياره همم
تاخذ قيمتها من المكانه التي ياخذها لبعض
وهي مكانه روحيه للزياره روحيه بروتونيه
القاهره الاستاذ احمد جمعه همم
تحدثنا عن البابا لكن هناك شخصيه اخرى لها
اهميتها في العالم الاسلامي همم شيخ
الازهر الدكتور احمد الطيب قبل ثلاث سنوات
كان مع البابا في الامارات وهو اليوم مع
البابا في البحرين همم ما هي رساله الازهر
في لقاءات كهذه
بعد التحيه لحضرتك استاذ اكرم وضيفتك
الكريمه من الجزائر بالتاكيد مشاركه فضيله
الامام الاكبر في مثل هذه الحوارات هي
مشاركه هامه للغايه في ظل حاله الخلط التي
حدثت خلال السنوات الماضيه ولجوء بعض
الكائنات المتشدده والمتطرفه لممارسه
الارهاب واستهداف الاقليات سواء في الدول
العربيه او حتى على مستوى العالم الخطاب
المتشدد الذي عاصف همم
المنطقه خلال الفتره الماضيه وادى لتعاظم
الارهاب وانتشار تنظيمات المتطرفه
والافكار المتشدده ليس في الشرق الاوسط
فقط والدول العربيه ولكن على مستوى العالم
مشاركه شيخ الازهر هي محاوله لتصويب بعض
الافكار التي يحاول الذين همم يزعمون انهم
ينتسبون للدين الاسلامي ترويجها في مختلف
الدول وبالتالي هذا الحوار مهم وتوقيت
الحوار مهم ايضا العالم يموش بالصراعات في
ظل يعني انتشار رائحه البارود التي تفوح
في كافه المناطق في ظل يعني انشغال دول
العالم باسراع في اوكرانيا الازمه
الاوكرانيه الروسيه يمكن ان تعود
التنظيمات المتطرفه في منطقه شمال افريقيا
او في دول الساحل او حتى في العراق وسوريا
تنظيم المتطرف تنظيم داعش الارهاب يحاول
ترتيب اوراقي مجددا تنظيم القاعده في بلاد
المغرب الاسلامي يحاول ان ينشط في شمال
افريقيا وتحدوده وتحديدا في الجنوب الليبي
يتحرك في منطقه الساحل وبالتالي يجب ان
يكون هناك تحركا كما نقول استباقيه يجب ان
يكون هناك حوار حوار مستمر وحوار صريح
وحوار شفاف كي همم نتوصل الى اليه يمكن من
خلالها محاربه هذه الافكار المتطرفه
الهدامه التي تحارب الحضارات التي تستهدف
الشعوب التي تستهدف الاقليات وبالتالي
حوار البحرين ملتقى حوار البحرين مهمه
للغايه مشاركه ملكه البحر ملك البحرين في
هذا الامر ايضا مهم للغايه الرساله التي
بعثها شيخ الازهر والبابا فرانسيس من
البحرين وتحديدا عندما غرس اا يعني نخله
في البحرين كارثه للتسامح وتعايش وسلام
الى الانسانيه جمعاء هو امر مهم للغايه
وتاكيد على اللقاءات السابقه السابقه في
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده يجب ان
يستمر الحوار يجب ان يكون هذا الحوار
مستمر بالتزامن ايضا مع حوارات ما بين
المسلمين انفسهم ما بين الشيعه وما بين
السنه كي يتم وقد اي محاولات لاسكان
الفتنه الطائفيه ودفع المنطقه
خلال السنوات الماضيه سواء في سوريا او في
حتى في العراق لذا يجب ان يكون هناك حوارا
داخليا ما بين المسلمين انفسهم يتم
بالتزامن ما بين الحوارات ما بين الديانات
الاخرى سواء المسيحيه او الاسلاميه او
اليهوديه
من الجزائر
همم الحبر الاعظم هو راس الهرم الكاثوليكي
في العالم هو زعيم دوله اسمها الفاتيكان
انما يتحرك يتحرك رجل دين ام يتحرك لاهداف
سياسيه
طبعا هو يتحرك اولا كرجل دين لكن لا يخفي
اهداف سياسيه بالطبع هناك يعني انحسار
لسلطه البابا ويعني يعني هناك حصار
للديانات في اوروبا نفسها وفي الغرب
وبالتالي هو يريد ان يعطي وهج للدور
الكنيسه ودور همم
الفاتيكان في في
الشعوب خاصه في شعوب شعوب شرق شمال
افريقيا لان هناك تضيق الشعوب شمال
افريقيا متهمه بالتضييق عن على
المسيحيين مثلا المعلم ديانات الاخرى وان
هو يريد من خلال هذه الفسحات او سواء كانت
الى الرباط او الى العراق والامارات السنه
منذ سنتين كلها يعني تطييب خاطر المسلمين
بالنسبه للمسيحيين خاصه انه في مثلا في
مصر المسيحيين الاقباط يعانون من الكثير
من اعمال الارهابيه وهناك كراهيه صارت
معلنه ضد ضد الاقباط وبالتالي هو يريد
حمايه حمايه هؤلاء
عفوا انا اتحفظ على هذا الامر الاقباط
ينعمون بالحريه الكامله نعم نعم الاقباط
ينعمون بالحريه الكامله يشاركونا في
الحياه السياسيه رئيس اللجنه المحكمه
الدستوريه الان قبطي لهم حقوق نعم نعترف
بها ويحصلون على هذه الحقوق هم شركاء في
الوطن
لا اعرفها سياسيه عملك
النظام المصري وليس من قبل المجتمع المصري
[موسيقى]
جيدا لكن هناك هذا لا ينكر ان الاقباط
كانوا مستهدفين خلال سنوات الاخيره بطريقه
بشعه
الاستاذ اكرم عطا الله
همم كلما تحرك البابا همم
ليس فقط البابا فرنسيس حتى الذين سبقوه
كلما كانت كان هناك تحرك باتجاه المنطقه
العربيه او الاسلاميه الا وطرح موضوع
الاقليات المسيحيه كان الحبر الاعظم عندما
يزور بلدا عربيا او بلدا اا اسلاميا فيه
دعوه للدفاع عن الاقليات المسيحيه هناك
الموضوع ربما
والحال المسلمين والموضوع اكثر
للحديث عن الموضوعات
انه المنطقه العربيه المسيحيه فيها اصيله
والمسيحيين ليسوا اقليون هم اصل في هذه
المنطقه
وهم جزء من شعوب عربيه
كلها شعوب متسامحه ويسجل لها انه بينما
كان العالم كله عنصريا ولا يزال كثير من
دول العالم تمارس العنصريه هذه غير موجوده
واعتقد الاستاذ احمد تحدث عن مصر وانا
الشعب المصري بصراحه يعني
اهل النيل ثقافه النيل العظيم العريقه
اضافه النهر ثقافه التسامح واللي من جديد
ربما نكتشف كل يوم اذا بحثنا عن تاريخ
فنان او سياسي بنعرف انه 30 سنه مثلا
انت لا تعرف انه مسيحي ومن هو مسلم مصر
يسجل للشعب المصري نهائيا في سوريا ايضا
نفس الشيء اما فلسطين
مش العرب لازم يحملوه جميله يعني
الفئات التي تتعاون مع البابا دينيا
وهذا يجب ان يكون واضح
حالات متطرفه ظهرت في المنطقه لم تكن
بمعزل عن ان تناسق مع دول مدعوم من
الولايات المتحده
اوروبا
الا عندما قامت هذه الشابه المتطرفه
بالاعدام 19 عام المصريين حينها تحرك
الازهر
عندما بيع النساء في سوريا وفي بيان شهير
بيان يعني يجب ان يخرج لكل المسلمين في
التاريخ اسمه بيان الرقه اللي همم
فرض جزيه على المسيحيين
اخبارهم يعني
في لبنان المسيحيين هم اصل وفي كل الدول
العربيه حيث ما يوجد المسيح هناك
ثقافه محصوره بين فئات مقدله متطرفه
اسلاميه وبكل اسف الاسلام المعتدل لم يكن
بتلك الجراه خلال سنوات الماضيه مع ظهور
هذه النزاعات العنصريه من بعض الاسلاميين
والمسلمين المتفرج
[موسيقى]
على الشيخ القرضاوي مثلا وهو حالي روحيه
رحمه الله عليه في العالم العربي
ما الذي يحدث على مستوى العالم العربي
ال 100 مليون 100 مليون في 100 مليون مصري
هم يعني لا تميزهم انه مسيحي ولا مسلم
مفيش داعي لنعلم الشعب المصري باعتبار ولم
ينزل التحدث مع الشعب المصري كيف يتاخر مع
المسيحيين وانت لليوم مش عارف مين هو
مسيحي من مسلم في مصر كذلك في سوريا كذلك
في فلسطين بالمناسبه انا اقول انا فلسطيني
استاذ انا بعطيك بعض اسماء انت بتستغرب
ربما انا اول مره تكتشف انهم ان هم همم
مسيحيين اقول لك مثلا رمز خوري
بحركه فتح نبيل ابو ردينه الناطق باسم
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه وهنا من اللي تاخروا
حتى
بمعرفه انه الاخ نبيل ابو ردينه يعني لا
يسال هذا السؤال وانا اقول لك ممكن تعطي
للاستاذ احمد بعض الاسماء المصريه ولا
يعرف انهما هؤلاء مسيحيونش يقدر لا يسال
هذا الموضوع هذا السؤال عيب في المنطقه
العربيه وبالتالي لا تؤخذ المنطقه العربيه
فكر عربي متقدم اكثر من همم اكثر من همم
يعني اكثر من الفكر احيانا هنا في اوروبا
والسؤال وهذا احس هذه احسن مقدمه
لسؤالي لك الاستاذ احمد جمعه في القاهره
هل للمسؤولين العرب مثلا في البحرين او في
الامارات او في المناطق او في البلدان
العربيه الاخرى الاسلاميه
القول على قول هذه الملاحظه للبابا همم
اهلا وسهلا بك جئت لي تدعونا لحمايه
الاقليات المسيحيه هنا لكن ماذا تفعل انت
هناك في الغرب في اوروبا امام تنامي همم
تنامي الكراهيه ضد المسلمين
نحن فعليا نحتاج الى منصه عربيه مشتركه
ليه نحارب ما يسمى بالاسلام وفوبيا في
اوروبا اا ارسال رسائل الى همم رموز الدول
الغربيه سواء رموز دينيه او رموز سياسيه
او ما الى ذلك يعني نحن على سبيل المثال
منذ ايام استمعنا الى يعني همم مصطلح غريب
من السيد جوز الفوري المسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا الوصف
العنصري الذي استخدم ضد الدوله العربيه
التدخلات التي تقوم بها الدول الخارجيه في
الشان الداخلي العربي هي التي افضل الى
الكراهيه هي التي ادت لانتشار الارهاب
والتطرف هي التي اعطت مساحات للكائنات
المتطرفه كي تنشط في دولنا العربيه نتمنى
على البابا ان يتشاور مع الدول الخارجيه
الدول الغربيه تحديدا التي لديها تدخلات
وانقراض سياسي وعسكري في دولنا العربيه
سواء في سوريا او في العراق او في ليبيا
او في السودان او في ايا من دول الاوسط
وان يوجه اليهم رسائل بضروره الكف كف
الاذى عن هذه الدول هذه الدول التي عانت
من التنظيمات المتطرفه من الخطابات
المتشدده من تدخلاتهم تدخلاتكم بعض الدول
وبعض الكيانات المتواجده في اوروبا مول
التنظيمات متطرفه استهدفت الاقليات
المسيحيه
واقلليات اخرى مسلمه في الدول العربيه يجب
ان تحاسب هذه الكائنات وهذه الدول على
افعالها وتدفع تعويضات للدول العربيه يجب
الضغط على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وعلى الدول الاوروبيه كي تضغط على اسرائيل
حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تنقل
بالمسيحيين في القدس ليه يعني نحصر عدد
المسيحيين في مدينه القدس في الرابع من
يونيو 67 ستجد عشرات الالاف من المسيحيين
كان ينعمون ويعيشون بسلام ماذا بعد 67
وحتى الان هناك عدد قليل للغايه من
المسيحيين في مدينه القدس وتحديدا في
القدس الشرقيه
نقل بهم من حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يجب
ان يكون هناك ضغوطات ودور اكبر للبابا ولل
الدول الاوروبيه يتم الضغط به على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على بريطانيا
على اوروبا نفسها كي يتم محاسبه اسرائيل
لانه هناك تنجيلا يحدث بالمسيحيين في
القدس الشرقيه يجب ان ننظر الى الصوره
بشكل عام لا يتم شخصا الامور والنظر الى
الدول العربيه او دول العالم الثالث نظره
دنيا كما نظر السيد جوز البوريل لذا نقول
يجب ان يكون هناك حوارا شاملا وصريحا
ومباشر يكون عنوانه المكاشفه والمصارحه
بشكل كامل نعم حزام همم موضوعنا الثاني
همم دخل فيه مباشره ضيفنا من القاهره الى
الاستاذ احمد جمعه بحديثه عن الله عن عن
الواقع الفلسطينيين وقعهم اليوم همم اكيد
يتازم هذا ليس سرا مع عوده بنيامين
نتنياهو الى
همم الى همم الى الحكم هل هذا مفاجئ همم
كيف حدث هذا كيف تنظرين هذا الموضوع
هو الوضع دائما صعب في الاراضي المحتله
وفي غزه كلها يعني تعاني من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ومن الباتش ومن الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقتل يوميا همم
الفلسطينيين بالنسبه لعوده نتنياهو اعتقد
ان ما كان به الفسائل الفلسطينيه همم
تحقيقها للوحده في ارض الجزائر اعتقد انه
ك- اخاف الاسرائيليين من ماذا دفعهم
لتصويت
درع ايضا مخرجات القمه العربيه التي اعادت
القضيه الفلسطينيه الى قلب النقاش وطرحها
على الامم المتحده لتقبل بدوله فلسطين
كعلوا كامل عضويه كل هذا
همم بناخذ الاسرائيلي الاختيارنا ياهو
الاكثر تشدد والاكثر تتطرف همم محاوله
للاحتماء به
الاستاذ اكرم عطا الله من لندن صحيح كما
تفضلت حده حزام هناك تقارب اليوم بين بين
الفلسطينيين همم
خاصه منذ اخر مبادره في الجزائر همم لكن
همم هل صحيح هل صحيح ان اسرائيل او
السياسه الاسرائيليه استطاعت ان تفرق بين
الفلسطينيين هل هذا صحيح ام هذه دعايه
اسرائيليه
انا تقصد انه اسرائيل سبب من الانقسام
الفلسطيني يعني هناك كلام كثير عن فرقه
فلسطينيات طبعا هذا واقع اييي لكن عندما
تتحدث مع المسؤولين الفلسطينيين كلهم تجمع
بينهم كلهم ايييي قضيه واحده يعني
بالنهايه يستحيل تقريبا لا يتفقوا على هذه
القضيه
تمام بالضبط اذا اذا كان هذا هو المحرك
الرئيسي
للقوه والفصائل الفلسطينيه
ومحرك القضيه الفلسطينيه
توافق على هذا الموضوع هناك
اختلاف الوسائل بين الفلسطينيين احدث بابل
الخلاف بينهما ولكن الاساس في الموضوع ان
الفلسطينيين هم منتج ثقافه هذه المنطقه
العربيه
الاقصائيه الاستمداديه التي لا تعرف
الشراكه التي لا تمارس السياسه التي جاءت
السياسه كتقليه للغرب وهذا الغرب اللي
تطورت عند السياسه
السياسيه كعبير عن المصالح الاجتماعيه
والتجار وصناع وغير وتحادات ونقابات
كيف سيكون الان همم همم الواقع الفلسطيني
امام عوده بنيامين نتنياهو
هل سيعزز ال ال الحاجه الفلسطينيه الشعور
الفلسطيني الى الى التضامن
لحظات كانت اكثر ضروره الى تعزيز الوحده
الوطنيه
الحروب والدم والمعارك وحتى هذا العام قبل
شهر وقانون الامس
الوحده الوطنيه هي ضروره فلسطينيه
زياده الفرقه بين الفلسطينيين والفلسطيني
بكل اسف كما قلت من الموضوع
ليس الموضوع الوطني
[موسيقى]
للحكم في اسرائيل بشكل
حمل معه بعض القوى ذات الطابع الفاشل
اسرائيل الليله هذا مش
تهمهم تستخدم المصطلحات في غير محلها
انا اتحدث عن احدهم نموذج الاعلى
الذي صنف باسرائيل باعتباره خارج عن قانون
الوصف شيء اسرائيل
يعني
اضغط عليهم هذا الحزن حصل على 14
[موسيقى]
تعليمات اطلاق النار
هذا اصبح الحديث
بالمنظومه
المصطلحات والمداخلات التي كنا داخلها
يعني منذ 10 سنين واكثر من 10 سنوات
موضوع
العالم
الاتفاق اللبناني اسرائيلي على الغاز هذا
الاتفاق اللي تم الشهر الماضي
تفضلوا ارجو ان يصل الرئاسه الفرنسيه
ونحن نتحدث على الوسيله اعلان فرنسيه
بريطانيا ويا ايطاليا ويقول دول العالم
كل جهودكم
على مدار العالم هذا الكلام انا وحضرتك
وكل السيدات والساده المشاهدين لا يعني لا
يعني هذا الكلام شيء بس هذا العالم
بكره بنسمع تصريح من راس الفرنسيه وبقول
على الطرفين العوده
واعلى الفلسطيني
رايك ما شاء الله المصالح والفرنسيه
ويطالب الطرفين بما فيه الطرف الفلسطيني
الايطالي
استاذ استاذ احمد جمعه من القاهره عنوان
هذه الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه نحو
ائتلاف حكوميه يمينا متطرف نقطه استفهام
همم همم هل هناك تطرف اكثر مما رايناه
بالتاكيد هناك يعني مع بنيامين نتنياهو مع
بن غفير هذا اشد انواع التطرف الذي يمكن
ان يمارس ضد ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني يبدو
ان اليمين المتطرف نجمه صاعد داخل الكيان
الاسرائيلي الغاصب المحتل الذي سيعمل على
التنكيل بشكل اكبر بالشعب الفلسطيني لكن
الحقيقه يعني انا ارى ان الفلسطيني هو من
يتحمل ليس الفلسطيني كمعطل ولكن الفصائل
الفلسطينيه التي انخرطت في لعبه المحاور
هذه الفصائل التي لا تريد نهايه الانقسام
وتوقيع عشرات الاتفاقات ما هي لعبه دكتور
ان تنقرض ماسحه وتنخرط الجهاد الاسلامي
الى محور اقليمي بعينه سواء الى المحور
الايراني او الى المحور التركي ضد محاور
عربيه واقليميه معتدله هذه الفصائل للاسف
يعني اغرتها لعبه الاموال ولعبه السلاح
ويعني تعاظم لديها يعني
النفوس تريد ان يكون لديها مال وسلاح لم
تنظر الى القضايا الرئيسيه المهمه للشعب
الفلسطيني
الوحده الوطنيه
في حد ذاته يعني اسرائيل ثلاثه ايام حماس
بان هذه ذراع ذراع ذراع ايران
للاسف للاسف فصائل فلسطينيه منقرضه في
لعبه المحاور هذه حقيقه هذا اولا ثانيا
حركه حماس وقعت عشرات الاتفاقات مع حركه
فتح لكن للاسف لا يوجد اي اراده سياسيه
داخل فتح او داخل حماس لانهاء الانقسام
الحركتان مستفيدتان من هذا الانقسام لماذا
لا يتم انهاء الانقسام لماذا لا تجرى
انتخابات رئاسيه وانتخابات تشريعيه وتجدد
شرعيه المؤسسات كي ينعم الشعب الفلسطيني
بحقوقه الديمقراطيه في انتخاب من يمثلوا
حتى الان نجحت اسرائيل في الوقيعه ما بين
الشعب الفلسطيني
وتحديدا عقب الانسحاب من قطاع غزه خطه
ريال شارون هيت كتكوت فك الارتباط عندما
قام بانسحاب فردي من قطاع غزه وحاصره قطاع
غزه وفرض نوع من الفصل الجغرافي ما بين
الضفه وما بين القطاع غزه بقت الهم الاكبر
للمواطن الفلسطيني داخل القطاع غزه كيفيه
الحصول على الكهرباء على الغذاء على
العلاج
المواطن الفلسطيني ينسى القضيه الرئيسيه
اتفاق الجزائر في اعلان الجزائر تم
الاتفاق على انهاء الانقسام وتحديد
الرزنامه تاريخيه لاجراء الانتخابات
الرئاسيه وايضا انتخابات برلماني
على ورق والفصائل الفلسطينيه لن تلتزم
باتفاق الجزائر او القاطع او الضحى
التصويره كما يقول الشعب الفلسطيني ذهبوا
فقط لالتقاط صوره لدور الجزائر التاريخي
لدعم المال الذي تقدمه الجزائر لنكن
صراحاء لن انفذ ايا من بنود اتفاق الجزائر
لنعد الى موضوعنا الموضوعنا موضوعنا
الثاني وقد يعني اقترب الوقت لن يدخل
الموضوع الثالث موضوعنا هو الواقع السياسي
الاسرائيلي الان
حتى هزم
المتعاطفين مع القضيه الفلسطينيه سيكون
عيبا شديد بالنسبه
على الفلسطينيين وعلى القريه الفلسطينيه
هل تؤمنين
فئه اسرائيليه مثلا بدات تفهم ان يعني على
مر ما حجر على مرما حجر او احيانا في الحي
ذاته في الشارع ذاته يوجد يعني يوجد ناس
ليس اسرائيليين هم فلسطينيون ولا بد من
التعامل معهم بواقعيه هل هذه الفكره برايك
موجوده في اسرائيل
من اسرائيل
انا لدي اصدقاء اسرائيليين على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي يدافعون عن القضيه
الفلسطينيه وعلى حق الفلسطينيين في تقرير
المصير اكثر من الكثير من موطنيين انفسهم
طيب موضوعنا الثالث ضيوفي الاعزاء هو هذه
القمه العربيه في الجزائر معك من القاهره
للاستاذ احمد
جمعه يعني بعد ثلاث سنوات من الانقطاع عاد
العرب من جديد اجتمعوا في الجزائر نسبه
التمثيل همم بلغت الثلثين يعني في اعلم في
اعلى هرم السلطه همم
يعني بشكل بشكل عام هل هذه القمه يعني
وجيز ايجابيه ام سلبيا
هي ايجابيه ان تعقد بعد ثلاث سنوات ويتم
التوصل الى هذه المخرجات وهذه الشواغل يتم
التاكيد عليها في البيان الختامي بالتاكيد
هذا ايجابي للغايه لكن يجب ان يتم تفعيل
ما تم الاتفاق عليه ما بين الزعماء
والقاده العرب هذا هو الاهم هذا هو بيت
القصير هذا هو ما سيجعل العرب سعداء
للغايه بالقمه العربيه وسعداء للغايه بدور
الجامعه العربيه الاهم هو تفعيل مكتوب
عليه تفعيل ما تم همم همم اخراجه في هذا
البيان الذي يتضمن نقاط هامه للغايه
ابرازها وقفه تدخلات الخارجيه حل القضايا
العربيه وفق رؤيه عربيه عربيه بعيدا عن اي
تدخلات من اطراف اقليميه لكن العبره
بتنفيذ ما اتفق عليه وتوقيعه في قمه
الجزائر هي قمه ايجابيه قمه لم الشمل
عنوانها وكان نحتاجه بشكل كبير يجب ان يتم
معالجه الخلافات البينيه ما بين الدول
العربيه هذه الخلافات التي نراها رؤيه
العين في سوريا وفي العراق وفي ليبيا وفي
عدد كبير من الملفات هناك خلافات بينيه ما
بين الدول العربيه حول اليه هذا حل هذه
الازمات ايضا القضيه الفلسطينيه هناك
خلافات بينيه ما بين الدول العربيه وللاسف
هذا سبب عدم التمكن العرب من حل ايا من
الازمات سواء في سوريا بعدم القدره على
تفعيل القرار اثنين اثنين خمسه اربعه
واخراج همم القوات الاجنبيه والمليشيات
والمرتزقه وكذا هو الحال في ليبيا الفشل
في تطبيق القرارين الامميين 25 70 و25 و75
وكذلك اثنين خمسه سته سبعه الذي صدر مؤقرا
لكن يعني متى نرى تفعيل هذه الامور سنرحب
بشكل كبير سنكون سعداء حال تم تفعيل ما تم
الاتفاق عليه لكن كما قلت هو اجتماع
ايجابي هي نقطه امل هو نور بدا يظهر في ظل
العتمه الذي التي عاشها العرب على مدار
السنوات الماضيه الاستاذ اكرم ع في في
لندن همم كانت هناك فكره سائده تقول ان
العرب اجنحه كل جناح ياتمر همم باوامر
دوله اا عظمى لكن هذا بدا يتغير همم بدا
يتغير يعني هنا في هذا في هذا المكان
احيانا جاء من السعوديه ضيوف يقولون
يتحدثون عن الحليف الامريكي ويذكرون كلمه
لانور السادات الراحل لانور السادات
المتغطي بامريكا عريان يعني راي سعودي
ينتقد النفوذ الامريكي يعني هل الان دخلنا
مرحله الوعي العربي ان هناك قرار عربي بيد
العرب والخوف من هذا
العراب الغربي او العراب الروسي او انتهى
انتهت الكلب الفتره
اشوف واضح انه العربي يراقبون التغيرات
موازين القوه تتبدل على مستوى العالم في
دروس بسيط في الحرب
المنطقه
وفي دول عربيه قيادات عربيه جديده في
العقل الاخير
تعيد اكتشاف مكان وقوتها بصراحه
لا يمكن الحديث عن الدول العربيه كما
الدول العربيه قبل 20 سنه
تغيرات هذه التغيرات ربما فاجاتنا هذا
العام مثلا
عوده النظر بالعلاقه الامريكان البيت
الابيض لكن
القمه العربيه
خارج من 20 سوداء 10 سنوات من النزيف
العرب العربي عشر سنوات من التامر العربي
على الدول العربيه
مين القائد الناتو في ليبيا يا دوله عربيه
واسقطت رئيس الليبيه دوله عربيه
وصدام
الدول العربيه
[موسيقى]
يتجمع الدول العربيه الدول العربيه
يتجمع الضعفاء
وراح يطلع منها هذا يعني يختلف مع من يقول
انه قمه عربيه مهمه وما اهميه تنوره
لكن غير ذلك مره بدون ان يشعر بها اي
مواطن عربي
ولم يلتفت
[موسيقى]
على تلك الاهميه
للجزائر اي دوله قوميه عروبيه اصيله لديها
رغبه بتوحيد الفلسطيني
هدزم
بعيدا جدا بهذه القمه ربما لانها اعادت
قضيه الفلسطينيه الى قلب النقاش وايضا
ربما ايضا السبب هو في بعض التعديم
الاعلامي لكبريات القنوات الفضائيه
العربيه التي كانت تهتم بالانتخابات في
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي اكثر مني اهتمامها
بالانتخابات
قويه والشعب الجزائري كان سعيد جدا على
غير يعني لم انا عشت عده قمم في الجزائر
لكن لم يهتم الجزائري بالقمم السابقه مثل
ما يهتم بهذه القمه طيب سؤال حتى حزام
سؤال عندما ننظر مثلا الى ما يحدث في مثلا
في اقليم اثيوبيا ونرى التدخل التدخل جنوب
افريقيا ثم تدخل الاتحاد الافريقي
وتقريبا حلت مشكله اقليم اثيوبيا هل العرب
اليوم قادرون على الانتظام لمثلا حل مشكله
واحده على الاقل تحدثنا عن القضيه
الفلسطينيه هل لهم القدره اليوم على حل
مشكله اليمن
في الحقيقه هذا الامر صعب لان المشكل بين
اليمنيين انفسهم بالنسبه مثل ما قلت في
تقرين هو اللي كان هناك نقاط طرقت لها
القمه بسواء في القضيه همم في القضيه
اليمنيه او في قضيه اعين
نفسها اليمن هناك هناك مثل ما اكد ال- ال-
الحل يرون في القمه على ضروره ابعاد
التدخل الايراني في المنطقه ولا يقصد به
التدخل في اليمن
في همم في سوريا وفي العديد من المناطق
التي تدعم فيها همم فسائل ضد الحكومه
الشرعيه وهذا همم
يمكن ان تحل الازمه لكن حاليا الازمه هي
في يد السعوديه التي هي التي تقول حرب
مدمره ليس فقط على على الحوثيين وانما على
كل الشعب
اليمني الذي تدق على راسه البيوت وهذا همم
هذه الازمه همم يعني عما قد منها السعوديه
في حد ذاتها والتالي صار يعني طرح القضيه
اليمنيه في القمه
التي تدخلت ايران التي تدخلت وسلحه
الحوثيين واستهدفت امن واستقرار دول
الخليج العربي وامن واستقرار المملكه
العربيه
السعوديه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الدفاع
عن مصالحها الدفاع عن شعبها اليمن ترتبط
بحدود مباشره مع السعوديه نفس الامر كما
يحدث في ليبيا كانت تستهدف مصر من جماعات
متطرفه مموله من الخارج وبالتالي تدخلت
مصر ووجه الضربات عسكريه لتنظيمات متطرفه
في مدينه دارنا كذا هو الحال في السعوديه
السعوديه يحق لها حمايه امنها واستقرارها
بلاد الحرمين يحق لها حمايه شعبها من
العمل في الايراني الذي يصلح الحوثيين
تعظم الصراع في اليمن بعد تدخل ايران
وتسريح الحو البيئه الطائرات المسيره
وبالمال والسلاح ايران تسعى لفرد الهلال
الشيعي في اليمن وسوريا والعراق ولبنان
وكافه الدول العربيه يحق للدول العربيه
الدفاع على امنها واستقرارها امن واستخراج
الخليج العربي خط احمر اي مواطن عربي
اخر اخر دقيقه من عمر هذا النقاش للسيد
الوحيد هنا همم تفضل للسيد اهل هزم
نا من المفروض ان يبدا الحوار هناك قبل ان
نرفع السلاح في وجه البعض في الحقيقه
الازمه هي الازمه
فهم مصالح ايضا السعوديه لا تدافع لا
تدافع عن الحكومه الشرعيه بقدر ما تدافع
على مصالحها والمصالحها لا يجب ان تكون
ضحيتها الشعب اليمني واطفال
شكرا لك كنت معنا من الجزائر اشكر كذلك
الاستاذ اكرم عطا الله من لندن ولك الشكر
كذلك الاستاذ احمد جمعه من القاهره
مشاهدينا الاعزاء همم انت هذا الموعد
التحليلي الاسبوعي همم تهليل الجمعه الى
اللقاء